oi tá bem renascentista que o nosso
ambiente hoje né comunhão com a natureza
e essa pulseira integração com a
natureza essa busca de um espírito de
aprofundamento cada um da sua maneira
buscando o melhor das nossas almas é o
que tem tudo a ver com o espírito
renascentista
ah pois é início ao tema tirei tenho
tratar hoje com vocês aqui que é fruto
de uma experiência e uma experiência que
tenham vivido no já mais de 10 anos em
viagens pesquisas mais viagens e
vivências pesquisas viagens livros isso
foi me abrindo a mente o coração a alma
para uma experiência que a humanidade
viveu que é uma experiência muito
importante muito interessante que é
justamente a experiência do renascimento
é o que que pessoas que viveram há 500
anos atrás
que poderiam nos ensinar
o dado esse lapso de tempo dado essa
essa relação em que as coisas mudam e
mudam muito rápido
a renascença foi um movimento o
movimento cultural de vendo a mente
importante e de muitas transformações
numa época em que o mundo a europa foi
resgatada de uma idade média e lançada
uma experiência diferente uma
experiência de aprimoramento humano e é
como poucas experiências que o homem
teve nossa história é o desenvolvimento
de múltiplas habilidades é que a gente
conhece muito através da história um
pouco da história que conhecemos dos
grandes pintores e grandes artistas do
renascimento nos demonstra isso
oi oi para além de pintores para além de
obras de arte o renascimento produz uma
obra e a obra mais especial que nós
podemos conceber que ele constrói que é
o próprio ser humano o ser humano é essa
obra extraordinária que existe como
objetivo e como finalidade no
renascimento
o ok então
nós começamos pelo tema que mais nos
toca e que mais nos chama atenção quando
o assunto é renascença que a beleza ea
beleza é fundamental porque a beleza vai
é operar no ser humano uma série de
aspectos junto a nossa psique junto a
nossa alma de fernanda e profunda
transformação
a avenida ela tem a capacidade de baixar
de fazer com que a nossa ansiedade os
nossos controles os nossos medos e
anseios se tornem leves isso vai sendo
substituído por ou preenchido por um
espírito de refúgio regozijo um espírito
de alegria profunda e aos poucos a
beleza consegue fazer isso de maneira
natural em cada um de nós ela opera isso
de forma muito natural muitos pontas né
com isso nós não precisamos raciocinar
mas não precisamos pensar sobre uma
pintura o sobre uma escultura ou sobre
uma obra arquitetônica ou uma grande
igreja extraordinariamente bem
construída e decorada como eram as
igrejas é renascentistas
e aí a partir daí a beleza vai operando
issue é muito interessante porque a
natureza como nós estamos vendo aqui ela
não aceita vazios né porque o próprio
espaço vazio que a gente tem aqui ao
redor tá sendo preenchido pelo canto dos
pássaros então tudo de alguma maneira é
é preenchido e até lisa ela o compra
esses passos fazendo com que a gente
acabe de alguma forma também nos
tornando mais plenos quando contemplamos
a beleza
e você na cientistas chamava muito
atenção dia que nós temos que ter muito
cuidado porque é para além
ah tá beleza exterior que é o que
normalmente nos apaixona é importante
que nós possamos contemplar a beleza e
interior da essência das coisas porque
essa nos inspira a paixão de alguma
forma ela nos aprisiona você nascentes
entendiam que apaixonar-se em demasia
gera sofrimento enquanto inspiração é
uma inspiração pela beleza nos liberta
nos inspira ok
e a partir da beleza
e evoluirmos as visões as visões e o
renascimento trabalha e trabalha de
maneira muito interessante na vida
quando nós de alguma forma aprendemos
algo que eu digo de estava nossa mente
para poder contemplar as coisas de forma
diferente para poder ver o mundo de
forma diferente isso nos leva a uma
mudança completa de modelo de vida
muitas vezes a gente acaba transformando
nossa vida em paz e a experiências que
são profundas o renascimento opera uma
mudança uma transformação aprofundamento
e uma expansão não só divisões de uma
coisa ou outra na vida de uma pessoa se
transforma a visão de mundo e aí vem
algo muito importante muito interessante
que pode se tornar um grande legado para
todos os nossos que é essa relação da
visão de mundo transformada pelos
renascentistas
e a gente pode entender basicamente e a
humanidade a visão de mundo nessa época
girava em torno de um eixo
é um eixo de poder que gerava cultura e
de tava os valores da sociedade que era
no a nobreza eo clero fumante estuda na
escola e é esse eixo de dominação entre
religião e política e na realidade não
era bem uma política e sim um plano de
exercício de poder e de comando e o
governo passa as mãos da própria
população e daqueles que vão representar
a população naquela época é não sejam
preconceituosos com tema com termo
burgueses porque são esses que saem sai
da dos campos e começam a criar as
escolas de ofício e aí todo o modelo a
religião que tinha uma visão limitada do
homem que ele tinha que ser p lente a
deus cuidar com seus pecados e toda uma
forma traumática e de dor utilizar com a
religião o renascimento
e retoma o modelo grego onde o homem ea
natureza e deus são uma coisa só que
estão fundidos seja ele traz essa
natureza divina como diziam os
renascentistas e como dizia o próprio
maior inspirador dessa visão que foi
platão para uma forma de vida interior e
todo esse aspecto de visão interior da
região passa esse conceito novo que a
gente tem aqui estávamos colocando desde
o início na introdução seja buscaram uma
reunião buscar uma harmonia com que
estavam em seu entorno e fundamente
fundamentalmente buscar uma harmonia com
os demais que estão a nossa volta
bom então aí a gente já viu um conceito
de religião e vai ver um conceito de
política também porque nessa época
pasmem a parte eu já de mim e 300
florença cidade que foi berço do
renascimento já era uma república
o segundo os segundo toda toda forma de
ordenação e de organização que já
existia desde a grécia florença era um
oásis no meio de um grande deserto de
vinha hoje os inovadores que é como o
vale do silício no mundo na cidade de
florença fazia esse papel nessa época
uma cidade com 150 mil habitantes na
época imagina é conseguia influenciar
cultural religiosa mente politicamente e
também óbvio que o que eu não falei
ainda com arte e ciência
em busca inspiração na natureza aqui a
gente vai ver a visão integrada entre
ciência e arte que fazia com que tantos
pintores escultores artífices desse
grande plano que foi o renascimento
pudessem brilhar tanto e marcar a
história com suas obras extraordinárias
porém essa inspiração e essa visão como
falei não existiria se não fosse a
filosofia a filosofia aqui entendendo-se
como busca da sabedoria e esses ideais
tradicionais que a filosofia resgata
desde a grécia olha só o que foi o que
fizeram os renascentistas eles passavam
a ter trajetos por toda europa
utilizando-se de religiosos de monges
das várias ordens religiosas que
existiam em florença
e estavam lá para rezar estavam lá para
buscar a sabedoria em todos os cantos da
europa porque eles tinham entrada franca
por onde quer que passasse diferente de
soldados de militares ou de governantes
existia um salvo-conduto para que ele se
deslocassem por toda europa então diziam
resgatando esses principais livros esses
principais textos dos grandes sábios do
ocidente e do oriente você já
conseguiram fazer uma fusão entre a
tradição grega grega e romana tradição
helenística como conhecemos também
contexto os árabes da filosofia
muçulmana e também das tradições
judaicas isso foi um grande um grande é
caldeirão de sabedoria que vai passar a
inspirar aos renascentistas naquilo que
é o eixo de todo o ideal renascentista
se você já que dá justamente a alma e o
espírito para que os renascentistas
conseguissem construir um plano tão
extraordinário e essa relação da busca
da inspiração da natureza é a gente vê
muito sobre a vida por exemplo de um
leonardo da vinci leonardo foi para nós
o maior expoente do renascimento porém
ele foi apenas um dos grandes é na
cientistas é não foi o maior de todos
inclusive segundo alguns dos próprios
críticos houveram muitos outros grandes
renascentistas e principalmente os
filósofos renascentistas que poucos têm
pouco conhecimento e eles foram educados
a
se conectar arte e ciência em tudo o que
faziam seja a ciência não era a despesa
de significado porque até então a idade
média pregava que ciência é o seguinte
era tudo que aristóteles já disse e tudo
que de alguma maneira a igreja já
compilou e pronto e não se discute mais
sobre isso então a aristóteles falava
que devemos observar a natureza porém
não interferir com ela devemos olhar de
longe e a partir daí fazemos as
interpretações e depois vieram os
escolásticos seja os doutores da igreja
e geraram mais uma interpretação sobre a
interpretação que aristóteles tinha né
para que isso ficasse muito bem
compartimentado e não tivéssemos nenhum
problema nessas interpretações o que que
fazem os renascentistas o que faz
leonardo o que o que fazem os mestres de
leonardo que fazem esses grandes
filósofos eles vão direto ao ponto
e inaugura logo que para nós hoje é
muito natural do processo científico que
a experimentação experimentar eu chego e
vou fazer a experiência eu próprio e
mais quase como um paradigma quântico
porque a experiência estava conectada
entre o experimentar dor e aquilo que
ele está experimentando
e havia essa necessidade de um profundo
ajuste de uma sintonia fina entre o que
eu vou fazer aquilo que é importante o
que eu devo perceber que maneira
profunda que nessa experiência como
leonardo fazia e e coloca nos seus
desenhos todos né onde se diz que se
foram mais de 100.000 páginas desenhadas
e escritas com as observações
científicas de científica de leonardo
que ele fala justamente sobre isso
enquanto ele observava as águas a
natureza os ventos os pássaros enquanto
estavam seus voos de como um objeto mais
pesado que o ar que o ar pode deslocar
ele ele fala sobre anatomia sobre a
circulação do sangue sobre o
funcionamento do coração e tudo isso
buscando algo que para os renascentistas
era fundamental e para nós também deve
ser a alma que anima as coisas o
movimento interno espiritual que anima
todas as coisas
o que de alguma maneira é o mesmo
princípio superpoint por isso é uma
coisa muito legal de entender o quanto
nós influenciamos na experiência daquilo
que queremos conhecer e quanto nós
devemos estar muito bem preparados para
poder contemplar aquilo que queremos
conhecer
a vocação e profissão tudo a ver com
isso você nascente essas me ensinaram
que vocação e profissão estão unidos
aquela questão de estarmos muito
preocupados com nossa forma de
sobrevivência sobre o que vamos fazer e
de fazer bem algo que sirva a sociedade
que seja extremamente útil os
renascentistas entendiam que mais do que
uma profissão não devemos procurar
primeiro a vocação
e o que é natureza a nossa natureza nos
chama
o que a nossa natureza tem a ver com as
coisas que estão ao seu redor saber
fazer essa leitura era algo
importantíssimo para um renascentista e
aí o que faziam os jovens vinhos desde
cedo passavam nas várias escolas de
ofício procurando ver qual que chamava
mais a sua atenção com qual ele se
identificava mais e a partir disso ali
ele começava a desenvolver sua
experiência então não seriam pintores
outros escultores outros ferreiros
outros boticários havia a todo uma
inovação relacionada aos medicamentos na
época a medicina já com com esse
processo todo vocação e profissão
estavam extremamente relacionadas e
integradas
o que nós não podemos entender com
mulher dentro separadas uma vocação
vocativo é um chamado entendi o
renascentista e para ouvir esse chamado
nós estamos nós temos que estar muito
bem internamente preparados
e para que algumas intenções segundas ou
terceiras não nos levem a passar às
vezes 10 20 ou 30 anos para nos darmos
conta de que o que nós realmente
gostaríamos de ter feito e o que nos
realiza com enquanto seres humanos seria
uma outra coisa
o que não aquela profissão profissão
desenvolve uma habilidade técnica
vocação desenvolve uma habilidade
interior
bom e nós vamos com a vocação
descobrindo quem nós realmente somos
ah e assim fazer o renascentista
um milhão é um modelo de vida para
podermos alcançar uma vocação para
podermos alcançar é o que nós realmente
gostaríamos de ser
a alma necessidade importante de alçar
as nossas ideias os nossos pensamentos e
a nossa busca para algo muito elevado o
mais elevado possível dizer os
renascentistas ideal significa conjunto
de ideias pelas sentir-se entender que
um conjunto de ideias contemplava
fundamentalmente algumas qualidades que
são o bem ou pelo justo o verdadeiro
isso já disse platão há muito tempo
atrás né ea necessidade de buscar em
tudo o que fazemos sempre essa guia
nesta isso é bonito isso é belo isso é
verdadeiro não verdadeiro como a última
concepção da palavra porque hoje dizemos
cada um de nós tem uma verdade cuidado
porque isso as vezes é algo que se
infiltra e que os renascentistas já
entendiam poderia ser um grande para
e como dizia a buda siddharta gautama
tudo a ver com o tema do nascimento né a
heresia da separatividade
e não podemos nos afirmar mos em
acreditar que cada um dos seres humanos
têm um ideal pronto não temos que ter um
ideal em comum e quando todos buscam de
alguma forma essas quatro estruturas de
virtudes ou de valores universais como
dizia platão nós chegamos a esse dela e
vamos construindo a ideia de um homem
universal
e pela primeira vez se lança no
renascimento essa essa esse nome esse
título homem universal a 500 anos que só
olha que coisa extraordinária mas o que
é um homem universal é esse que está
conectado com todas as coisas assim mas
fundamentalmente conectado consigo
próprio sabendo que ele quer sabendo dos
seus anseios e sabendo das suas
habilidades como vamos desenvolver nosso
verdadeiro potencial se nós não temos
uma meta um caminho a seguir esse nós
passo a passo enquanto trilhamos esse
caminho não sabemos que ele está
conectado diretamente com a nossa
experiência de vida e na construção
desse homem objeção o que chama atenção
para vocês eu pedisse que trouxesse uma
imagem que representa o homem universal
na renascença sei que metade aqui
pensaria logicamente no homem de
vitrúvio aquela imagem do ó
é inscrito que não circo e não quadrado
alguém já perguntou porque um círculo
porque é um quadrado porque o quadrado é
o símbolo da matéria é o símbolo do
mundo concreto é um de nós vivemos as
nossas experiências ea maneira prática e
concreta e o círculo onde a dois homens
praticamente né hum que toca o circo
outro que toca o quadrado depois vocês
podem conferir o que toca o circo é o
homem conectado com o cosmo conectado
com as estrelas como dizia da 20 é não
se pode parar não se pode ir para trás
aquele que tem como meta as estrelas
bom então esse é o ideal do homem
universal e essa é a ideia trabalhada
pelos renascentistas para desenvolver
todas as pessoas aí estavam método de
educação que tem relação direta com os
mestres da renascença
ah ah não existia ninguém que fosse um
discípulo avulso ou solitário na
renascença eu fui descobrindo através
dos meus estudos todos eram discípulos
de discípulos de discípulos e o mestres
de discípulos e mestres de se proteger
essa cadeia era forma de educação na
época
e hoje eu tô querendo falar aqui para o
público grande ou seja são 100 pessoas
que estão aqui quem sabe o escutando
algo que pode abrir uma pequena chispa
uma pequena chama de inspiração porém
importante fosse de que vocês
procurassem alguém para estar mais
próximos em cada um de vocês que pudesse
acompanhá-lo no seu crescimento na sua
evolução na sua experiência nas suas
buscas nos seus anseios que ajudasse
vocês a enfrentarem seus medos esses são
os mestres
e com as pessoas que marcam a nossa vida
porque conseguem se conectar diretamente
com a gente consegue transmitir não são
conhecimento técnico mas
fundamentalmente é uma experiência de
vida leonardo por exemplo para citar
esse que todos nós conhecemos seu mestre
e vocês já devem ter ouvido falar quem
estuda um pouquinho da sua biografia
chamado ver tóquio tóquio significa olho
verdadeiro
e olha só quem era seu discípulo
leonardo o sujeito conhecido por ter a
melhor capacidade de observação que o
ser humano já teve na história um cara
impressionante sei lá vamos traduzir em
uma linguagem atual envia e bilhões de
pixels enquanto a gente vê uma coisa
assim mais ou menos né é muito pouco
definida quatro de era o sujeito ea
gente nem nem dois deixo ainda bem essa
é a capacidade de observação mas não só
pequeno uma capacidade de observação de
detalhes físicos e sim de algo que movia
internamente isso naquela coisa que ele
queria conhecer e isso eleva a alma não
tira não nos aliena
e essa relação com os mestres nos tira
de uma forma de vida simples e ficar
pensando só na fome na violência nas
dificuldades em pagar boletos e talvez
seja o pior de todos os nossos problemas
parecem tão interminável né como a vida
no universo então nós temos que tá mais
despertos e procurar ajuda os mestres
podem preencher esse aspecto ok
e para mim seja bom chegando já ao fim
você sabe em viram que eu comecei pela
beleza e estou terminando
e pelo amor usando a cientistas fit no
pico della mirandola ou seja os
principais mentores filosóficos do
renascimento em um o amor como ideia é
fundamental a obra prima se um dia vocês
querem ir à florença não deixem de
contemplar lá meia hora a fúria da
primavera ali são expressas as sete
formas de amar
e o cupido é um anjinho lá em cima como
a flechinha apontada é só um anjinho não
esse anjinho simples e puro é o símbolo
do amor universal aquele amor que une
todas as coisas e dá sentido a todas as
coisas vemos que está logo abaixo dele
representa o amor na natureza em todos
os reinos da natureza logo tem três
graças unidas que é o amor a alegria é o
amor é da pureza e é o amor a da beleza
também presente no quadro e depois tem o
amor ao mistério é um mercúrio está
afastando as nuvenzinhas para que eles
não entrem em florença e contaminem é
como assim estamos afastando a idade
média daqui
é porque atrás é existe um bosque de
laranjeiras e a laranja era o símbolo da
família que era a grande patrona grande
bosque representando florença e logo
você não vê assim uma forma um tanto
etérica sendo levada pela imortalidade
que é o símbolo daquela imagem com asas
que justamente o espírito de florença
e o que os mentores os filósofos do
renascimento pediram a botticelli parte
de um grupo chamado fideli delamore não
seja os 6 o amor olha que coisa linda
não é um amor passional como falei não
era um amor cara não era um amor muito
espiritual e no teu levado eles queriam
contagiar com esse amor todas as pessoas
então obras renascentistas para nós são
como amuletos a gente chega na frente e
fica desarma desarma os nossos controles
e algo muito com invadir a nossa alma
oi e aí está isso é o amor que venha
através de uma chave zinha aberta pela
beleza e depois mexendo isso todo o
trabalho de um grande real a busca de
sábios a mudança de visão os mestres a
filosofia e horas e horas e horas de
estudo de diálogos de convivência entre
esses grandes pintores porque antes eles
aprendiam filosofia antes eles
aprenderam sobre si mesmos para depois
desenvolver a sua arte ea sua vocação
então amar é fundamental para que nós
possamos unidos todas essas contas e
encontraram verdadeiro sentido em tudo
que fazemos
não tem isso de fato não poderemos
alcançar o que é um legado
extraordinário que nos mostram os
renascentistas e que pode ser
extremamente último extremamente
proveitoso para todos os nossos
e renasça
a todos os dias da sua vida buscar a
beleza ao redor nos que a beleza nas
coisas que tem um significado música
beleza inclusive nos desafios nas
dificuldades porque aí também está uma
forma de aprendermos como a natureza se
manifesta
e busquem é visões romper com visões
limitadas na vida de vocês porque elas
podem ter servido em algum momento porém
à medida que caminhamos temos que
aprender também a nos desapegar dessas
visões por visões ainda mais profundas
por visões ainda mais é significativas
para todos os nossos ao mesmo tempo
busca em aprender com os mestres isso
nos dão certo atalho na vida e nos poupa
muitas vezes de muito sofrimento de
muitas coisas que nós poderíamos
aprender sem precisar apanhado
é porque mesmo isso na vida vai fazendo
com que cresçamos interior mente
o yanmar bom para mim todas as coisas
amém todas as pessoas mesmo aqueles que
às vezes você acha que não são
merecedores do seu amor por que só o
amor vence o medo vizinhão os
renascentistas só o amor gera o
verdadeiro conhecimento ea verdadeira
ciência sobre as coisas dizem os sábios
da renascença e enfim renasci renasci
são todos os dias todos os dias que
possam da sua vida é
olá sejam felizes muito obrigado a